well in the long run democracy has to be
the answer I mean you know as I may be
wrong but everything I've been taught in
the ivory tower or everything I've
learned from reading about the rest of
the world will tell you that
authoritarianism ultimately it's not
tenable it's a band-aid strategy it
would work for two years five years ten
years but end of the day it's
inconceivable that the Middle East can
continue to grow in terms of demography
then continue to open up to the world
and learn the things about Internet
technology modern society etc and yet
and the gulf between aspirations of the
people and the government that they have
becomes wider and wider and nothing will
happen
I mean logic will dictate to you that
ultimately authoritarianism will not
last and we do see breakdowns look at
Pakistan in the past year or so we
thought that the story in Pakistan is
about moderation versus extremism this
is what we try to market and the
Pakistani said wait a minute that is not
the story your story's about freedom and
rule of law so we have the bizarre
episode
you know pictures on new york times of
policemen with long beards beating up on
lawyers in suits that's the opposite of
what we assumed would be who who should
be beating whom but the reality of it is
that we will see more Pakistan is
happening we can not gauge it we have to
realize that in the short run
authoritarian regimes may serve
short-run security stability interests
of the United States but in the long run
at some point in time authoritarianism
will no longer be the solution as we saw
in Pakistan will become itself the
problem the dilemma for u.s. foreign
policy is that or what we know is right
morally and what we know what should
happen in the long run is one thing and
our short-run needs are different and
our short-run needs does not serve
things that we know ought to be true in
the long run
and we have never been able to bridge
this gap in fact the Bush administration
is probably the first one which at least
at the level of rhetoric tried to create
a bridge between what is good for the
middle east in the long run and say well
you know that's good also for the united
states in the short run but it bungled
the whole thing so abysmally that we're
back to the old old way of thinking with
a vengeance
nobody everybody says yes in the long
run we shall all live in the Nirvana of
democracy but in the short run our
friends are the dictators